hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast an ongoing evaluation of
our transient expression systems can we
predict the appropriate expression
system for any drug modality presented
by Richard Richard our Altman a
scientists in the protein technologies
mammalian expression group at Amgen San
Francisco we are excited to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
by lab this event is sponsored by thermo
Fisher Scientific and this live
broadcast is brought to you by libraries
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you'll be viewing the presentation
in the side window your enlarge the
window just click on the screen icon
located on the lower right and if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem please join me in welcoming
dr. Richard Altman I will now turn the
presentation over to him thanks Kristen
for that kind introduction first I'd
like to start with the important things
and that's thanking the organizers for
the invitation to participate in this
excellent online conference both for the
invitation to speak and then also
especially to Rick babsi for the
invitation and also for the organization
of the conference and I also I'd like to
thank Henry Chu and johnson-luna
for their assistance and organizing this
as well so I've shortened the title a
little bit from what Kristen had read -
can we predict the appropriate
expression system for any drug modality
and the short answer if you want to skip
the rest of the presentation
is we're not there yet but what I'm
hoping that we can do is we share the
next several minutes together is sort of
see a what the importance of this
question is and how we're going about
answering it with some experimental data
so far and what we're planning or what
we're looking forward to and then also
tying in some ideas of not only
answering this question but but about
how we increase the efficiency of our
protein expression process so I think as
you see on the the introduction here
with an ever expanding array of protein
formats really one of the next larger
challenges that we see is being able to
strategically match a construct with an
expression system and I think this will
become a little bit more apparent as we
go through some of the following as some
of the subsequent slides in order to
really take a look at this
experimentally what we've done is to
utilize a diverse set of proteins
comparing material that we've
transiently produced in a number of
systems including the HHH 293 6e the XV
cho and the XP to 93 systems both for
expression level and product quality and
I think I want to stop there and make it
a special point about the product
quality I think is and again as we'll
see in the end future slides the titer
has been the focus for many of us in the
expression field for a number of years
but I think it's as titers have
increased the idea of product quality
has taken a more formidable sort of
position at the table in terms of
important attributes as we go about
fulfilling requests and generating
and what is this allow us to do you know
and hopefully what it does is is we can
prioritize expression systems we can
maybe potentially limit the number of
expression systems we have and what we
can do there is reduce parallel effects
and increase our throughput efficiency
and with that efficient increased
efficiency there are some social quint
efforts that I'd like to talk about at
the end of the talk that increase our
efficiency of the whole process and
again I think that's an important topic
as well when you look at increasing
efficiencies is not just the expression
portion of it but if you look at the
whole process really from cloning
through analytics how do we reduce that
total cycle time in the whole process so
I think one of the fundamental questions
I always suggest is that we take a look
at what do we want to do what do we want
to establish and one of the things is
establishing or optimizing these systems
to meet them to meet the demands of our
protein production and one of the terms
I like to use often is strategic this
strategic selection of expression system
not to find this a little bit more in a
subsequent slide but really the main
goal is here is how do we build an
appropriate expression toolbox to
support drug discovery efforts and
there's no right or wrong answer here I
think that it's going to be certainly
everything is going to be you know
specific to your particular expression
lab or expression facility but I think
it's an overall idea that we need to
continue to focus on and I think the
constraint we're sort of the border that
we have or would like to live within
about this is that when we talk about
this when we talked about looking at
systems or optimizing systems that we
don't want to lose sight of this term of
ease of use and I think it could come
down to a risk reward or how much effort
you're putting into something for the
for the reward outcome and I think for
any of these things as scientists we
always think we can tweak another one
2% out and some of in some cases that's
very important and you want to do that
but I would argue in a lot of cases this
isn't necessary and so when we go
through these processes and try to carve
out in inches of time from our
day-to-day work to methods optimization
or looking at different methods that we
keep that it's sort of a guiding line
for us so in today's discussion with
with everyone I'd like to look at you
know this evaluation optimization of
transient expression systems and we're
going to talk about strategic selection
of expression systems and cell lines so
we're going to look at a little bit give
a quick review of the expression systems
that we have here in our facility what
are their advantages sort of what are
their sort of characteristics
what advantages do they bring to us
right now and how are we doing in terms
of getting to the point of assigning
them specific formats for expression for
the specific expression systems then we
want to I want to jump gears and talk
about scalability and maybe down in the
sense that the traditional sense but in
a couple of different ways and I think
that will become apparent in a few
minutes and then also talk about
optimization and both the scalability
and optimization are going to are going
to come back into this whole efficiency
topic in terms of how we choose systems
and how we do it most with the quickest
turnaround time and then we want to step
back and look at a couple of dress about
process challenges that I think are
interesting for facilities in general
about how we go about some processes
that are fairly time-consuming but we
hope they have some leads on on how we
make these sort of time-sink projects or
time seeing portions of the process more
efficient for us to allow us to do other
things so let's go to that first bullet
point and talk about strategic selection
of expert
systems or cell lines so we might ask
the question well why why is this
important or why should we do that and I
and I think this slide is is a good
start or a good graphic representation
of that I think when we think back in
two years 15 years or so ago when we
look at what we were expressing and
predominantly and blued we were
expressing a lot of just traditional
monoclonal antibodies which you can see
there on the panel on the left this
panel on the right is from a recent
review article in 2015 from spicy el
which is showing a number of formats of
by specific antibodies and as the
protein engineering has advanced so has
the number of formats in each of these I
think in our own way can represent
challenges for us in terms of expression
levels and product quality and in terms
of maybe one size or one expression
system doesn't fit all of these the
following couple slides are from a
review article from yogurt at all which
they took a look at all of the cell
lines that have been used for transient
protein expression and here on the first
page you can see a number on the
left-hand side the left panel of 293
based cell lines and then starting in
midway down on the right hand side a
number of chose and this continues on
onto the next page of additional code
lines and then a couple of newcomers or
necessary newcomers but others that are
added in there including the cap T cells
the and we need a cite derived cells and
then also the Vera cells the African
green monkey kidney cells but I think
when we really think about it when we
looked at all of these things it really
sort of boils down to
at this point some commonly used lines
for transient protein production and
that really centers on HHH to 9-3 cells
on the left and cho cells on the right
and I borrowed this slide from Henry Chu
is presented this before but is a great
summary slide of the advantages of both
you know for the 293 is obviously for
years and years these have been the cell
lines of choice they're highly
transected they've given grapes
they've given excellent titers they have
bend the cell line of choice but many of
us in the protein expression world since
most biotherapeutics are produced in
showed arrived cell lines have always
hoped for a chow line that we can do who
that we could use in a transient
paradigm that would allow us to create
material that's more representative of
what that final product is going to look
like from a production line but it's
been difficult with the transect ability
it shows cells but with advances in both
in both methods of transmission in terms
of electroporation and then also from
the launch of the XV Cho system we now
have some choices that we can generate
material with post translational
modifications that are more in line with
what we're looking for in a much more
transparent element what I would say is
one of the challenges that we have here
with our choice is do we always have to
go into Cho's house and I would say the
answer there is no I think there's still
a lot of applications that we can use
293 cells and I think as I said I'll
point out some advantages of that a
little bit later in the talk but now we
have that additional tool of the Cho's
when we when we need to use it in a
transient setting and this is just to
remind myself and I think in everyone
else this just represents from a recent
paper it's sort of the the pathways and
barriers to gene delivery and really on
a sort of very high level point of
the difficulty in the complexity of the
whole process and what we need to do to
sort of at every step whatever we can
control and optimize to help that to
healthy wholly efficiency if the process
is important from the choice of
transfection whether we're going on the
lipid route or electroporation to the
health of the cells to conditions like
that it's not meant to be a depressing
slide in terms of the complexity or
variabilities but I think just a
reminder of how fascinating and complex
this whole process really is so when we
talk about here to get into the
evaluation of the expression systems
when we talked about the cell line
strategic selection what I mean by
strategic is I've already spoken to is
can we predict which expression system
will give the optimal tighter and
protein quality for any protein format
and you can tell from all of those
formats that we have I'm not sure that
we'll ever be able to 100% do this in
fact I'm pretty convinced that we won't
be able to but I think what we will be
able to do is to at least give us some
educated educated ideas of what systems
to go into and you see at the bottom of
this slide some of the transients the
transient expression systems that we
routinely use here in San Francisco we
utilize the xB 293 system the xB chose
system and also an alternative protocol
to that the high density xB Cho and then
we also use the 293 6e expression system
which historically has been valuable to
us over the last number of years
traditionally we've used a free style
f17 expression media with that system
but recently we have done some
experiments in terms of equilibrating
this with the balance CD system from
irvine scientific and we're finding some
encouraging results
with that at this point and they all
have if you look at a comparison of
these systems in a sort of tabular form
as in this slide you can see here that
when you look at I've had four
categories here what I think are
important considerations for these
systems there is a variety of the amount
of plasma that's used for transfection
in any of these systems and one of the
things you'll see an asterisk there is
when we're talking about optimizing gene
dosing in this expression system and in
a particular expression system this is a
topic that we're going to speak about
later in the slide but as we do larger
and larger transients expression runs
the whole idea of how much minimizing
the amount of DNA we can use is a very
important thing both from a cost and
from a process point of view but you can
see here we're running anywhere from
about 0.2 micrograms per mil up to a
microgram per mil but we're especially
interested in the both the 6e system and
the xB 293 system about doing some
additional gene dosing experiments and
like I said we'll talk about that a
little bit later in the presentation the
densities vary in terms of the density
of transfection and they run anywhere
from one and a half to two million per
mil with the 6e system all the way to 10
million per mil and the SP geo high
density and i think one of the important
things for us is that it's the harvest
time and you can see here the range that
we're experiencing with the 6e system
we're looking at about a week seven days
of expression time in the xB Cho system
the the multiple systems in the in the
in the xB Cho is running anywhere from
seven to fourteen days depending on the
protocol that you run but one of the
advantages I think with the xB 293
system that we've seen
and again it's the ability to really
harvest early at day four with a minimal
level of loss of titer with that so we
we can transect that a Monday and
harvest on a Friday and have a very
quick turnaround time for a number of
applications and this sort of drove our
interest and and experimentally work
into looking and validating more the
high density ex vitro system in terms of
getting it down to a date for harvest
and we've had pretty good success with
that I'm not going to share any or show
any data about that today but I think as
we look at in a broader picture how
transients are stacking up against
stable cool processes these days I think
it's an incredibly important
consideration in terms of the days to
harvest can we keep transients transient
and so I think pushing those back is
certainly a goal of ours to the quickest
sort of time to harvest and then we
talked about advantages and then the 6e
systems have theoretically extended
expression times due to the generation
of the the epital one protein binding to
the where EP in the plasma as we've
mentioned in the in the 290 trees that
time the harvest is really is really
great both from the expression point of
view and then also from the whole
process point of view and then also as
we talked about in the expert so the
post translational modifications are
much more in line with what we're seeing
for products that are made in show lines
therapeutics that are made in choler so
have all these systems in place and now
so how do we go about sort of figuring
out what each of them what their
strengths are and how we can use them
best and I think that one of the things
that we have found I'll give you a quick
thumbnail on these is that with the XP
chose we see excellent tighter in
excellent product quality for the most
part in the generation of regular maths
and as will circle back to later on this
is this is for Austrade at the moment
this is their strength but the next set
of slide the next set of slides are
going to show the difficulty I think in
trying to do this because there's always
exceptions to these sort of rules and
this is and this is one of these cases
where we had a traditional map and if
you look here on the slide the panel on
the left is a non-reducing portion of
the gel on that side and then on the
right is the reducing portion and what
we've done here is we've taken the same
map the same construct and done a small
scale expression 30-mil expression in BO
in 293 60s in the XV 293 s and then the
XP chose these are different days of
duration the 60s and the XP chose are
seven days the XP to ninety three or
four days and when we look at this when
we characterize the material we're
expressing we look at octet when
possible and then run on SDS page and
what you can see here is that if you
look at the chart on the right that when
we looked at that that the expression
level certainly was enriched in the XP
293 and XP Cho over the 60s we were in
the range of 4 to 500 in the XP systems
and about 150 in the 60s but then
that the second part of that talking
about product quality comes into play
and so when we looked at this on a gel
you can see here up in the up in the 150
range we're now in the 60 and the xB 293
we're seeing in this area at around 150
where we would expect the majority of
the product being migrating with the
show we're seeing certainly some of that
material but also we're seeing a level
if you look down the lane of additional
products being generated and so this is
one of those examples most of the time
it is but not not true for the xB chose
the xB 293 here was would be the system
of choice and that's what we did and in
the subsequent slide is showing a
Western blot showing here again that the
this is against sa human IgG heavy and
light where again the product quality is
clearly much better in the xB to 93 and
to some extent in the 6e except we have
better tighter in the xB to 93 then what
we're seeing here in the M speech show
in this sort of this next slide just
sort of reinforces the idea of the
increased titers that we see with the xB
Cho and if you look what we what we've
done here and that left side of the
panel is there are the conditioned media
titers and then the purification yield
on the left side for for maps that were
expressed in the 60 system and then on
the right side in
the XP Cho system and again as you can
tell here that the fighters have been
much more enhanced in the in the system
in the XP chose system than in our
previous system and when we have done a
couple of these in parallel in the small
and I'm sorry in the high-density system
and what we find is that the titers are
very similar that well as what we're
seeing in the in the seven-day standard
protocol so it's it's one of those
switching slides here or trying there
with me a minute
yes actually if we can get some
assistance in changing that that would
be great I'll continue to talk through
this I apologize for the the problem
with going to the next set of slides
what I was going to say is what I'd like
to show on the next set of slides here
is that what we've done is to take
another set of molecules and in this
time not just thank you for that not
just not just NAB's but in this case
also fusions
so if you look on the left side of the
of the gel we have non reducing
conditions and on the right side we have
reducing conditions and we have three
different fusion monoclonal antibody
fusion proteins and then in the first
three lanes here in lanes one two and
three and then a traditional map and
these are all in the xB Cho system and
you can see here again that they have
all performed very well we have
differing tighter as you can see in the
xB Cho system that the first one is is a
little bit less tighter of 150 but then
we see excellent titers in the 400s and
then the mAb in the in the 500 they're
set I'm sorry in the seven onions and
you can see at the bottom with that map
that we're seeing really good yields in
this that we're getting about 350 360
mins per liter out of that and from the
purification point of view we're seeing
excellence in terms of excellent
homogeneity in terms of the SDS page and
the mass spec data so just sort of
reinforcing where we're a strength of
the XP geo system is and then this
represents again a fusion that we ran in
XP Cho and it's giving us a little bit
more of a challenge and what you can see
this is through the purification on the
left there
the the lane one is the load through
that flow through and then often the
first column in lane three and then the
Aleutians in four and five and if you
look under reducing conditions here in
six and seven off the purified material
we're seeing we're seeing a band in the
around fifty KD that really shouldn't
really should not be there wait about
there and the last act is basically
indicating to us that we're getting some
clipping issues and as you can or as
you'll be able to tell as we're moving
forward this is one of the the
challenges that were we're having with
the system balancing off the really
advantage advantageous part of the
monocle and production and post
translational modifications now this
this slide represents a a protein that
we use for acid so it's a reagent
protein production but this was
interesting in the sense of taking a
step back this was expressed in the HEK
290 360 line a long time ago so it was
some historical data with this what we
did and i and i don't have the time to
show you the data in here is that we ran
that's a comparison of the of the 60s
the XB to 93 in the x beat show and with
this particular protein what we found in
the past had worked with was with the 6e
system and harvesting at day 3 because
there was some susceptibility to
degradation and we saw that with the
other cell lines as well if this gave us
the opportunity to not to look at this
additional or this new media from irvine
scientific in terms of the balance CD
and one of the from a presentation of
pep talk recently one of the advantages
of this is that it's a should give
higher titers with the same cell and so
we wanted certainly to investigate that
and what we did was sort of a
combination of looking
ss system and doing a gene dosing
experiment and what I mean by the gene
dosing and we'll like I said we'll talk
about this a little bit more in detail
later is to not only just reduce the
amount of DNA but to reduce your DNA of
interest and keep the amount constant
that's being transfected but keep it
constant with a amount of empty vector
and so if you look here at the F is the
slide on the left in Lane in lane two
you see just an IG standard and I'm in
lane three what you see here is a
purified standard of the protein of
interest in that that's right in there
and then we look through here and what
we're doing is we're doing both 0.2
micron micrograms per million one
microgram per mil in in triplicates here
where we're looking at mach and then
point two micrograms per mil one
microgram per mil and this is the
control amount that we saw in the F 17
media and as you look across what we see
is is that by the time we get to day
seven that the that the winner here for
us really is the is the less amount of
DNA at point two micrograms per mil that
gives us much more robust expression of
our protein of interest certainly as
compared to the material we take it out
in day seven that we experienced before
we're seeing a lot of disappearing of
that material so if you if we run a
Western on that just to sort of
reiterate that you can see here this is
a an antibody against that protein of
interest that we're seeing really
excellent amount of immuno reactivity
here with that at the day seven at the
point two microgram per mil so it gives
you an idea of the amount of iterations
that
having or 10 user brings it there on
these different systems or with these
different systems and different media
and how it's so much an ongoing sort of
process so this is as I said there are
many more examples we can talked about
at the side-by-sides and what we're
doing here is not only you know with new
experiments taking a look at comparisons
but also we're historically going back
and looking at material that we've
generated in these different systems and
really trying to with a lot with a high
end value come back and say how are we
going to probably ora ties our systems
and this just shows sort of where we are
at this point with what we look at or
how we look at our systems in-house so I
think from the system that we use the
most is really the XP 293 system and
it's you know huge advantages are really
the time to harvest as we've spoken
about and what we've experienced is that
it works with a variety of formats and
as I mentioned before I think for most
of the applications that we use it for
it's a perfectly acceptable cell line to
use to meet the needs of those
applications now what are we doing in
terms of optimizing that what we talked
about gene dosing generally in the past
I think the recommended amount is a
microgram per ml I found we can go down
to a half a microgram per ml and that's
just a dilution of the DNA there's no
gene dosing replacing keeping the amount
of DNA constant and replacing with empty
vector but that's something we're doing
right now the safety system I think
because of the advantage is it seems to
be given with the with the additional or
different media and it's time to harvest
is is giving us is probably our next
go-to and I think a big thing there as
I've mentioned is
it's historically used in the system
we've expressed a lot of proteins and
I'm sure many of you get the same sort
of thing that you get refills or you get
requests again and again for different
proteins and here we have a source we
have a source of expression system that
we can go back and we know we've made
this material and it's been a good
product quality the ex vitro system is
something that we are using it we feel
well-suited to traditional mat formats
and you know it has the advantage of the
post translational modification we're
working diligently to really
characterize other formats and and to
see between different cell line
conditions and maybe different
engineering on the construct if we can't
make that the umbrella of the XP Cho
system even wider for our use but I
think and you know at the position we're
at right now this is this is where we
feel most comfortable with the yeast in
the system and I think when you put the
three of these together what it creates
for us is that is a fairly good toolbox
that we can address the needs of most of
our requests but as I said there's still
work to be done in these orders might
change as time goes on I think an
interesting points you know to think
about is how many systems do you need
you know it would be great to go down to
one system and have it fit everything I
just don't think in the near future that
this is a sort of viable sort of place
but that might change too in the in the
coming years but for this for at this
point this works well for us so I want
to talk about scalability and I and I
think most of what I want to talk about
is small scale screening to support this
expression selection so you know when we
talked about how did we how do we go
about running these side-by-sides and
it's fine we can run these in 125 ml
flask and do 30 ml expression studies
but one of the things that we've
recently set up that I think is
incredibly helpful for us is to do these
at very small scale in a
higher throughput in a 24 deep well
plate and whether we're using whether
we're using a TP n here and doing it in
very high throughput sort of mode or
we're just doing it manually depending
on the number of constructs what we can
do is transparent expression systems and
then harvest these volumes and then hand
it off take a look quickly at the
expression analysis whether octet or SDS
page or even caliper higher throughput
and then hand this off to our colleagues
and expression in there behind
throughput affinity purification either
with protein a or nickel nta or whatever
and then that expression time it's about
an hour and a half for them to do at
this scale and then we have a follow-up
analytics where we can now get not only
what's the expression level but what's
the quality of the protein are we seeing
aggregation or whatever and we've used
this effectively for a few times in
terms of them being able to within a
week or so or less even sometimes come
back and say you know really we should
choose you know expression system a for
this particular format it's also very
viable in the sense of when you have
something novel that we don't know
titers but we're pretty sure of
expression system it to gives us the
ability to scale appropriately so that
we're not just doing an educated guess
but we actually then with just a you
know an extra week or so built in then
we can scale up appropriately so we're
not over shooting or under shooting and
creating additional work for ourselves
and then I think you know one of the
challenges that dovetails into that is
just having the ability to do the scales
that are necessary and and you see here
there's a whole variety and we
experience all of that from the deep
well plays rate to the wave bioreactors
and so having those in place are
critical but that small end
really I think it's going to speed up
the efficiency of our process and allow
us to make really good decisions moving
forward so we talked a little bit about
optimization and you know we've
mentioned this idea of gene dosing
there's a lot of variables here that
should be considered to improve
expression levels and product quality
and you know we discussed choices cell
line we'll talk about gene dosing here a
little bit more in a couple slides but
there's also many others and I just
mentioned temperature iteration of
culture DNA quality I think is a topic
that people are aware of but probably we
should pay more attention to moving
forward and then also with the
production of antibodies to stoic
geometry of the heavy chain light chain
ratios that we are transparent but let's
let's talk just a little bit more in
depth about the gene dosing and you know
really it's it's a useful strategy not
only for obviously saving DNA but for
generating difficult to express
molecules and we're basically doing what
we're doing here is decreasing the
transcript to match the secretory
capacity in the cell mostly with the use
of the empty vector with all of the the
elements the promoter elements and so on
that are there in the empty vector
they're acting as a transcriptional
factor sync and to sort of modulate them
the amount of transcript so hopefully we
can create a higher-quality product that
is less prone to aggregation so again
varying the amount of coding DNA being
transfected and then again the sort of a
collateral benefit is that the means
that increase plasmid needs and this is
an excellent example from a paper that
was published a couple of years ago by
my colleague Graham Estes and his
colleagues down in our Thousand Oaks
facility where if you look at this that
gene dosing can improve the product
quality but if you look at the form of
carrier DNA it can make a difference and
a lot of times when we think about this
we think about that a lot of times we
would use the salmon sperm or sheared
salmon sperm
as you look across this is a fusion
protein and you look at the gene dosing
percentages from a hundred all the way
over to two and you know with the shared
salmon sperm DNA you do see some
improvement of this from all these
multiple species here in the aggregation
to something that's more more amenable
here that's running about 95 to odomes
the same thing with this blue script
vector in the middle panel again you're
seeing some is some improvement in terms
of the aggregation properties but in the
panel on the Left where they use the
specific vector that was done in the
expression system the PT t5 in this case
you see by the time you get down to ten
ten percent and five percent that now
we're generating a pretty good a nice
much nicer product of higher quality and
this is something like I said that we're
going doing on an ongoing basis for both
of those reasons both for constructs
that are generating materials that are
prone to aggregation or clipping or
whatever and then also as a way to
reduce our DNA needs in the future and
in the last couple minutes I just want
to talk about the efficiency of the
process and and talk about a couple of
things that we're doing to sort of
address that and I think this slide is a
great reminder of this is that if you
think about it it's not just about titer
anymore this is a figure taken from a
recent paper where you know back in the
90s the thought of creating or early 90s
thought of creating a gram of material
transiently was met with skepticism to
say the least but now by the mid 2000s
you can see that you know the ability to
generate material at five to ten
her leader and cell densities of very
high is not unusual anymore so it really
isn't just about tighter anymore it's
about like we said that the quality and
then speeding the whole process and how
are we looking at that well there's
there's a couple of ways here and I'm
going to go to this the second one first
here in the sense of the process
efficiency between cloning and
expression and purification groups I
think this is something not to be
overlooked we won't speak about this in
this presentation but when you think
about it I think there's a lot of white
space in between those times where
constructs are generated and the
material is purified and how we go about
in communication is a big key here how
we go about getting these passing doing
handoffs and so on is is really an
important consideration but I'd like to
just talk briefly about some emerging
technologies and really focus on the
bioreactor harvest process which if we
look at the next slide traditionally and
I borrowed this from a presentation of
my colleague ray Loewy if you look at it
you know well we've run stuff especially
this is true at higher scale that you
know we have the bioreactor and then
we're faced at harvest to do
centrifugation and then subsequent
filtration and then column purification
in this whole central Gatien step as
many of you are aware especially if
you're dealing with ten liters or 20
liters or more is really a time sink and
it really ties someone up for a number
of hours to get this through both the
centrifugation and the filtration well
is there a way we can really sort of
start to get around this and the answer
is yes although there's not a rigid
process in place at this point this just
shows here one of the ideas that were
pursuing and that's abusing for
especially for large scales the
these GE Joule filter cassettes where
we're basically just hooking this up to
a wave bag here and then pumping through
the filters both a glass fiber five
micron and then a point two micron
sterilization filter p/es filter and
then into a sterile bag but basically
once we make the connections with these
we can walk away and people can be
engaged in other activities in the lab
while this goes ahead but of course this
is now without you know some
optimization and getting it you know
getting the right parameters in place
the first few times we ran this we
really ran into some issues about I
think that the speed at which we were
pumping through the material and we were
really damaging the cells and so we took
a step back to some optimizations on
flow rates and then did a study where we
took twenty liters took our pretty much
our optimized what we thought at the
time optimized conditions and then
instead of harvesting into a bag we took
two liters aliquot so to speak and then
looked at this both by octet and by
sds-page and what we found is that you
can see here from lanes or on these are
just subsequent fractions is that pretty
much the product looks the same and the
titers until we get right to the end as
measured by octet and as as visualized
here by sds-page are pretty consistent
so I think we've found ourselves some
parameters where we can where we can you
know harvest this reliably without much
loss of material and this is an ongoing
process for us at this point and a
second sort of exciting thing that we're
also investigating now as you see this
traditional column process here on the
on the left that we
earlier but then one of the things that
were working on in collaboration with
our colleagues down in Thousand Oaks is
this mag beat process where we're taking
magnetic beads that are coated either
with protein a or some other effects ISM
and then putting these in the bag the
night before harvest letting them bind
and then just using magnetic rods
harvesting them out of the bag rinsing
and eluding and the whole time here is
you can see in this panel as we've we've
shrunk the time down to the harvest
being about an hour and a half or so and
not only just the harvest time but what
we've done effectively is a first step
purification and a concentration step
and up here you can see the comparison
between the mag beads and the matcher
select traditional method you can see
similar sort of recoveries and yields
and product quality in this system again
this is a sort of a work in progress but
again it would allow us to sort of free
up some time from this fairly mundane
process to do other things so in summary
I you know I think it's important about
moving ahead and with all of these
different formats trying to be as
strategic as we can with our expression
systems but having a sufficient amount
of these systems to meet the needs of a
really divergent set of constructs that
were faced with expression and then you
know in line with that you know
increasing the efficiency of our protein
production process and I think they all
tie into both of those ideas tie into
one another but I think I'd like to say
that streamlining the harvesting method
represents a really good example of that
of that thought process
and with that I would be remiss not to
acknowledge my colleagues here
throughout the organization for all of
their for some of their data for their
excellent thoughts and communication and
I'd also like to very importantly thank
all of you for taking the time out of
your busy day to listen to this and I'm
happy to respond to any questions that
you might have thank you very much thank
you Richard for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for so let's get started our
first question is when do you use XP to
93 versus actually Cho for your bio
therapeutic development work and how
much is distance election protocol
dependent versus protein dependent yeah
that's a great question so I think is
you know in terms of you know early on
for us in India or sort of early
discovery stage they're sort of
intertwined to answer that question I
don't know I'd like to think we'll have
a better answer to that in about six to
twelve months in terms of what drives
what they're I think that you know the
constructor that protein is going to you
know kind of drive which system we
choose but I'm still not there in terms
of making that prediction but like I
said that is the goal ok great the next
question we have thanks for your great
talk do you think that XP Cho expression
is somewhat predictive for issues one
can suffer later on during cell line
development and could the somewhat
better product quality of XP hack be
misleading later developability yes and
that's a great question I've had I have
a good example of that I think that
we we had one time where we were
expressing an on antibody
that certainly was in the in what we
were looking at it for as a potential
therapeutic and we expressed it
originally in XP 293 and express very
well and we went through the
characterization and decided to move the
the process forward when we gave it to
the statement that cell line development
folks and they put it in to chose they
came back a number of weeks later and
said look we can't find anything that is
of high enough titer for us to move
forward with and so retrospectively we
went back in and put it into XP Cho and
you know lo and behold if it would have
been indicative I mean we really got
quite low expression and I think that's
you know it's a great point by the
person asking the question is that you
know that that is a secondary advantage
of the system is that you know using it
as a tool to say that and we had one
other example of that where it was
predictive of downstream problems okay
thank you the next question we have do
you do any labeling of your proteins no
I don't I I never have and so I don't I
don't really have any experience with
that okay for the next one it says what
type of constructs require carrier DNA
to decode transfected well that's that's
a great question and that's sort of what
we're trying to figure out as well I
think we're putting together you know
like I said some bins of different
formats that might require that that
maybe are more prone to aggregation
depending on you know linkers and
what's attached to what but we're not
like I said we're not quite there yet
with that I think that right now we're
doing that sort of retrospectively where
you know we can go back and do gene
dosing or with the I think the advantage
of the small scale so we could even
expand that experiment not to only be
cell systems but to do gene dosing
experiments at a small scale to really
hone in on that as well okay what is the
future of transient protein production
that's a very good question so um I
think it's very interesting in the sense
and and this is something you know I
think it's a great discussion to have a
whole bunch of people in a room and talk
about this but I think one of the things
with the advances and how quickly we're
making stable pools it really puts the
pressure on transient protein production
to be truly transient so if we can
generate one liter expression runs out
of stable pools that have gone through
selection and scale-up within three
weeks or so and we compare that to
trying to do say in the case of X beat
show a 14-day mix tighter run you know
we either have a stable pour we have a
single run sort of thing that only
differs by seven days so I think that
like I said the pressure is on and this
is why we're sort of pushing to move
those transient duration of runs to as
quickly as possible so yeah I still
think there is certainly a future for
transient expression but I think there
is going to be continued
pressure to continue to optimize the
system whatever system you're using okay
looks like we have time for one last
question does the 293 or Cho system
express a protein with better native
glycosylation pattern
I'm sure Christian can you say that one
more time
sure does the 293 or Cho system
expressly protein with better better
native glycosylation patterns yeah so
we've done some experiments actually we
just published a paper about that in
general expression and purification but
what we find in we looked at a couple of
a couple of proteins that we had
expressed in production lines versus
material generated into 93's and xb2
93's next we chose and certainly the XP
shows are giving us you know a much
better a more expected like an pattern
than what we see necessarily in the 293
and some of it can be I think you know a
word of caution depending on the
protocol that you use but certainly the
data would indicate that you know we're
seeing something that we had hoped for
is that it's more more in line with what
we're seeing in the production line and
so that was that was a really good
result to see okay
I would like to once again thank you
Richard for your presentation and I
would like to thank libraries and Thermo
Fisher Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible additional
questions will be answered and published
on Thermo Fisher Scientific website you
will receive an email notification when
answers are available before we go I
would like to everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through April of 2018 you will
receive an email from Maverick sweating
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event that
all for now and thank you for joining us
we hope to see you again soon goodbye